so president trump i think he's uh a lot
a lot better for women
than any of this kind of stuff and by
the way you just track it too there have
been a number of
surveys done of happiness so take it
with a grain of salt
but since women's liberation since we
were told that
degrading sexual activities uh actually
empower women
women's happiness has declined
precipitously
both relative to men obviously you know
and in absolute terms it's declined this
idea that women are going to be
empowered and happy and
flourishing uh it hasn't happened the
opposite has happened but we can't let
trump off the hook
this trump made a comment it was sexist
misogynist
chauvinist east ist i don't know it's so
terrible the left is furious
he was asked about the vice presidential
pick and you know kamala harris or
any of these other women he said well
you know biden said he was going to pick
a woman and i think a lot of men are
offended by that
take a listen first of all he roped
himself into
uh you know a certain group of people
he said he had to pick a woman he he
said that and you know
some people would say that men are
insulted by that
and some people would say it's fine i i
don't know
look some people would say that okay i'm
not saying that but maybe i could say
that if i wanted to say that
which i haven't done but some people
certainly have
i love the trump circumlocution to just
get ideas out in the world
he's absolutely right men should be very
offended by what joe biden said
not because he picked a woman running
mate i don't think
she is going to help him in particular
but that's not it's not the fact that he
picked a woman
it's the fact that he's picking a woman
simply for being a woman
he's picking a black person simply for
being a black person as if to say
i don't care about any of the qualities
that this person has
i just want to check this box and so i'm
going to cut off
half of the population more than half
the population because he said it has to
be a black woman
i'm going to cut off more than half the
population i don't care what the content
of their character is i don't care about
their virtues
because i just want to check this box
the individuals the people don't matter
we're riding this wave of history we're
on the right side of history so you just
have to fill in the slots
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts